pop les républicains bonjour fans
rudulier bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec vous faites partie de ces nouveaux
sénateurs élus au mois de septembre on
va en parler mon va balayer l'actualité
1 d'abord avec vous et l'actualité c'est
cette crise sanitaire emmanuel mâcon qui
est donc attendu ce soir à 20 heures
après un nouveau conseil de défense
ce matin il devrait annoncer un petit
peu de desserrement du confinement en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on entend qu'est ce
que vous en attendez vous du chef de
l'état écoutez ce que ce qu'on en attend
c'est du bon sens du pragmatisme et une
vision à moyen terme pour sortir de la
crise sanitaire qu'est ce qui s'est
passé depuis plusieurs semaines je
prends l'exemple des bouches du rhône on
a eu entre mi-août et fin septembre dix
mesures contradictoires sur les bars et
les restaurants
comment voulez vous donner de la
confiance dans la gestion de la crise
si tous les quatre matins on change de
directives par rapport au bar et au
restaurant donc effectivement il faut
sortir de ce confinement du desserrement
de la stratégie avec des étapes de la
progressivité pour éviter la bonne
méthode pour vous une sortie progressive
en plusieurs temps mais je pense parce
qu'il faut éviter
forcément une troisième vague au
confinement faut éviter la stratégie du
stop and go qui démoralise la plupart
des français donc il faut de la
progressivité dans le dans la sortie du
du confinement
il faut des étapes clés il faut des
indicateurs également transparent pour
donner en fait aux français la véritable
mesure de la crise sanitaire et après
foulard n'est pas le cas pour vous on a
des points presse régulier notamment
tous les jeudis de la part d'olivier
veyrat il ya un manque de transparence
sur la vision à moyen terme et à long
terme du gouvernement quant à cette
sortie de crise sanitaire
la question est de savoir pourquoi on a
maintenu des commerces de proximité dit
non essentiels fermées alors même que 50
m après on avait des cavistes ou des
barres de 2,2
des bureaux de tabac ouvert c'est une
question de bon sens et de pragmatisme
là aussi au delà des indicateurs au delà
du comité scientifique
il ya également certains aspects qui
doivent être reprécisée et puis deuxième
point c'est la stratégie vaccinale
il faut l'anticiper il faut que les
régions il faut que les départements il
faut que les communes soient clairement
associé il ne faut pas que ce soit une
décision verticale qui viennent de
l'état je vous rappelle qu'un enjeu
notamment au niveau du stockage au
niveau de la logistique on parle d'un
stockage à -72 degré du vaccin qu'il y
ait deux campagnes de vaccination
puisque l'on aura deux paravents deux
interventions sur les personnes pour
pour les vacciner la stratégie sur les
personnes les plus vulnérables
on sait que les départements sont chefs
de file notamment au niveau des ehpad
il faut travailler avec les départements
sks que c'est le cas comment ça se passe
ce dialogue a écrit si vous étiez maire
avant d'être dominateur en vous étiez
maire d'une commune qui s'appelle rognac
est-ce que ça s'est amélioré
ce dialogue avec les élus entre la
première et la deuxième vague oui il ya
eu des efforts
il ya eu des efforts qui ont été
notables mais entre converser essayer de
débattre pour trouver des compromis des
consensus et avoir une information
descendante régulière c'est deux poids
deux mesures faut pas confondre la
communication descendante avec une
véritable concertation et là encore
l'état des efforts à faire en la matière
allez cette crise sanitaire elle
entraîne une crise sociale a aussi avec
10 millions pauvres c'est le chiffre
annoncé par lé par les associations
l'état ne peut pas tout c'est ce que
disait lionel jospin mais est ce que
l'état vous trouvez qu'il en fait déjà
beaucoup est ce qu'ils n'en fait pas
assez par rapport aux pauvres jeu
écoutez je pense qu'il en fait il en
fait déjà beaucoup mais ils devraient
cibler beaucoup plus ses interventions
quant à la pauvreté ou seysses il ya eu
10 millions de pauvres ça date pas de la
crise la crise sanitaire il ya un fossé
effectivement qui se creuse on est dans
une société duale où les riches
deviennent de plus en plus riches et les
pauvres deviennent de plus en plus
pauvres il suffit malheureusement d'une
crise sanitaire ou d'une crise
économique pour replonger certains qui
étaient prêtes à s'en sortir dans dans
la provôté et pourquoi ça a été ça dans
votre département cette augmentation de
la pauvreté lg à cette crise bien sûr
mais tout part de coin il faut
revaloriser encore une fois le travail
cette grâce au travail qu'on sortira
également les personnes de la pauvreté
ça veut dire qu'il faut tout faire pour
que des personnes puissent accéder soit
au premier emploi soit trop retrouver un
emploi afin qu'ils puissent avoir des
des revenus est derrière sortir de cette
spirale de la pauvreté
il ya cette crise sanitaire et à cette
crise sociale et puis il ya une
troisième vague qui pourrait être une
vague psychologique
olivier ferrand l'a dit la santé mentale
des français s'est significativement
dégradée est ce que vous êtes inquiet de
ce sujet en particulier peut-être pour
les jeunes
oui alors inquiet sur le sur le sujet
forcément mais ça dépend aussi de la
stratégie de sortie de crise qu'il va
qui va être actée par le gouvernement il
faut rassurer rassurer les français est
au minimum qu'on voit de la lumière au
bout du tunnel
à l'heure actuelle ce qui plonge le
morales qui plante le moral des français
c'est malheureusement qu'on a
l'impression que cette crise on n'en
verra jamais la fin après la crise
sanitaire y aura la crise économique et
après la crise sociale c'est à dire
qu'on va plonger le pays dans une
sinistrose durant cinq années non il
faut impérativement donner des
perspectives afin qu'on est tous des
objectifs communs pour sortir plus fort
de cette crise et lesquels nous
contacter à calais ce quick est de
donner des perspectives
sinon mais en fait à chaque crise il
faut changer de paradis changer de
paradigme économique c'est de dire de
développer de réinvestir des branches
entières de notre de notre économie de
réindustrialiser parfois des secteurs
entiers qui ont été totalement dévastée
depuis des décennies afin de donner un
espoir une espérance aux français parmi
les personnes touchées ya des personnes
qui vivent dans ces quartiers
défavorisés il ya une centaine de maires
qui ont lancé un appel la semaine
dernière au chef de l'état pour que
hambourg sont du plan de relance à evere
ces territoires vers ces quartiers
défavorisés jean castex a reçu neuf
d'entre eux hier il a dit oui il a dit
oui un milliard de ce plan de relance il
ira bien à ces quartiers défavorisés
c'est une bonne chose pour vous oui
c'est une bonne chose mais il faut aller
plus loin dans ce plan de relance si
vous regardez il ya dans le plan de
relance ya 40 milliard d'euros sur le
plf 2001 consacré à ce plan de relance
effectivement qui est un milliard
d'euros pour ses quartiers défavorisés
c'est bien mais faut pas oublier que la
relance économique ont demandé tout à
l'heure me demandiez des perspectives la
relance économique c'est aussi à travers
les collectivités territoriales à
travers les communes à travers le départ
les départements qu'elle va se faire 50%
à 75% du pib
si on compte les dépenses militaires
sont
exclusivement investis par les
collectivités territoriales
il faut fléché fléché je dis bien des
dotations d'investissement aux communes
aux départements et aux régions pour
relancer l'économie à travers les
collectivités territoriales rien et ça
ça manque cruellement dans le prend dans
le plan de relance mais notamment dans
le plf 2020 ou le fonds de solidarité à
l'investissement local et du même niveau
du même étiage qu'en 2020 et je pense
que ça va faire défaut
j'ajoute un point c'est que ces 40
milliards de de relance la lenteur de la
du décaissement de ces 40 milliards
d'euros qui a été d'ailleurs souligné
dans l'avis de la cour cour des comptes
est très inquiétant quand vous regardez
l'allemagne 5 - 5,8 pour cent au niveau
de son pib
nous sommes à -11% la réactivité de
l'allemagne par rapport à la relance et
économique est deux fois supérieure à
celle de la france ça veut dire beaucoup
de choses et il faut tenir compte des
territoires et c'est par les territoires
c'est par la relance à travers des
territoires qu'on arrivera à sortir plus
vite de la crise et on va continuer à
parler bien sûr des territoires et des
finances des collectivités locales
puisque on va parler du du budget mais
on va d'abord parler fiscalité
écologique puisque c'est ce dont il
était question hier soir au sénat en
phase avec alexandre poussard
[Musique]
bonjour ryan bonjour stéphane rue de
lille bonjour et le sénat qui a donc
débattu hier de la fiscalité écologique
il était question du malus auto dans les
prochaines années
oui effectivement oriane le malus
automobile sur les émissions de co2 des
véhicules neufs va augmenter dans les
prochaines années ça c'est une certitude
tous les responsables politiques sont
d'accord mais la question c'est à quel
rythme et oui le gouvernement au départ
avaient prévu une hausse de ce malus sur
deux ans
l'assemblée nationale finalement a prévu
une hausse sur trois ans et hier soir le
sénat a étalé cette hausse du malus du
malus automobile sur cinq années
avec cette mesure est bien le rapporteur
les républicains du budget jean-françois
husson veut rendre plus acceptable la
fiscalité écologique par aller français
est bien de manière à éviter une
nouvelle révolte fiscale alors il a pris
quelques exemples d'abord d'abord la
révolte des bonnets rouges contre
l'écotaxe et puis il a pris un deuxième
exemple que tout le monde connaît la
crise des gilet jaune
on écoute le deuxième exemple c'était le
raidissement très verticale de la
contribution carbone c'est appeler comme
ça c'était même je crois contribution
climat énergie la taxe carbone en clair
ici même un certain nombre d'entre nous
avions tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur
l'incompatibilité de l'acceptation de
nos d'aidé français sur cette pente trop
vertical le résultat des courses vous
l'avez et on s'en souvient
particulièrement le pays mais ici aussi
puisque savait entraîner des dégâts
importants dans paris c'est la crise
dite des gilet jaune très d'ailleurs en
2017 jean-françois husson faisait partie
de ceux qui avaient alerté un an avant
la crise des gilets jaunes sur ce risque
de révolte contre la fiscalité
écologique
alors il n'était pas tout seul il y
avait aussi le sénateur écologiste ronan
dantec mais bien cette année ils ne sont
plus sur la même longueur d'onde et
l'écologiste ronan dantec veut aller
vite dans la transition écologique
on l'écouté nous n'avons pas un malus
très clair et sûr des délais courts pour
faire en sorte qu enfin les
constructeurs automobiles comprennent le
signal parce qu'on voit bien qu'ils
jouent plutôt l'a montré ne sont pas les
seuls dans ce cas là
ces débats nous avons régulièrement ici
si nous n'avons pas effectivement ce
signal très très clair nous allons
encore perdre plusieurs années plusieurs
années or nous n'avons pas ce temps là
stéphane le rudulier est-ce que face à
l'urgence climatique il faut ralentir la
transition écologique comme ça a été
voté hier soir ralentir la transition
écologique nos par contre passer d'une
fiscalité punitive à une fiscalité
incitative
oui on a toujours le réflexe en france
quand on veut changer de paradigme
d'essayer de changer les comportements
des français à travers une fiscalité
punitive
je pense que c'est l'essence même de la
crise des gilets jaunes
il y a deux ans pourquoi pas on parlait
de changement de paradigme tout à
l'heure avec des mutations économiques
inciter les constructeurs automobiles a
abandonné le diesel et l'essence est
véritablement passer à des énergies
propres et donc investir massivement
dans ce dans ce secteur-là avec des
aides potentiellement de l'état c'est
une question que je pose plutôt que
d'essayer de contraindre le consommateur
on parlait pas voter vous croyez
sincèrement que quelqu'un qui est en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté va penser à
changer sa voiture pour passer du gasoil
à une l'énergie renouvelable les
priorités ne sont pas les mêmes est-ce
que je me fais comprendre donc à partir
de là qu'est ce qui se passe
eh bien on a une révolte qui part des
classes sociales populaires et ça met le
pays à feu et à sang au qu'il faut dès
qu'on parle de fiscalité écologique il
faut être très prudent
et ça veut dire que cette révolte des
gilets jaunes à peut repartir selon vous
il suffit d'une étincelle coûté moi je
pense que le sous jacent dans la crise
duco vide a mis sous cloche
la crise des villes jaune mais je pense
que le malaise sociétal est toujours
bien profond est toujours bien présent
en france on va continuer à parler de
cette qualité écologique alex puisque
dans ce débat le sénat peut-être
d'autres mesures en faveur de
l'environnement
oui oui un débat très riche sur la
fiscalité écologique ou lieu d véritable
apport du sénat sur cette fiscalité
environnementale les sénateurs ont
réduit la tva sur les billets de train
ils ont également incité les compagnies
aériennes a acheté à des avions plus
propre ils ont pris des mesures pour
développer les biocarburants à base
d'éthanol et puis ils ont affecté ça
vous concerne stéphane heureux de lier
une part de la taxe carbone aux
collectivités pour appliquer plus
facilement les accords de paris sur le
climat et puis il ya un autre sujet qui
vous concerne stéphane le rudulier il
s'agit des paquebots de croisière alors
ça concerne le département des bouches
du rhône et plus précisément marseille
où ces paquebots de croisière qui
stationnent dans le port de marseille
représenteraient la moitié des émissions
de co2 des voitures de la ville donc
c'est un vrai sujet et puis c'est un
paquebot de croisière il bénéficie
d'avantagés fiscaux ils ne paient pas
ils ne paient pas la taxe carbone et
hier soir les écologistes ont souhaité
supprimer cet avantage fiscal alors en
temps de crise la majorité de droite du
sénat refuser la suppression de cette
niche fiscale pour ne pas fragiliser et
bien le transport maritime et on va
regarder à la déception du sénateur
écologiste joël labbé auteurs de cet
amendement qui dit et bien vers 22h30
c'est l'heure des débats sur les niches
fiscales quand on maintient la niche
fiscale pour les paquebots de croisière
en même temps refusé de l'accorder aux
bateaux des ong qui travaillent en mer
et sont reconnus d'intérêt général à une
poignée de voix près stéphane le
rudulier est ce que cette niche fiscale
sur les paquebots de croisière c'est pas
une injustice écologique et sociale non
mais c'est ces deux c'est surtout la
temporalité est ce que c'est c'est le
moment effectivement
d'essayer d'anéantir les niches fiscales
je ne pense pas on parle de relance de
l'économie ce les paquebots de croisière
font partie également de notre de notre
économie
donc il faut il faut un juste équilibre
peut-être que dans un an peut-être que
dans deux ans quand on sera sorti de
cette crise sanitaire et qu'on verra le
bout du tunnel de la crise économique il
faudra remettre à plat notre fiscalité
mais vous savez le débat sur la
fiscalité on parle la fiscalité
écologique ou écologistes mais il est
beaucoup plus large on parlera tout à
l'heure sans doute la fiscalité locale
il faut repenser notre fiscalité mais
totalement profondeur en france pour
éviter justement qu'elle soit perçue
comme une injustice que ça soit en
termes de corporatisme qu'en termes des
français par rapport à leur niveau de
ressources et on va en parler tout de
suite dé cette fiscalité locale on va
remercier alex a tout de suite avec sa
voile à la revue de presse de stéphane
rudulier plus largement sur cette
fiscalité locale évidemment laquelle le
sénat est très attentive
il a voté la baisse des impôts de
production le sénat s'est voulue par le
gouvernement est ce que pour vous c'est
une bonne chose ou est ce que cette
baisse des impôts de production qui a un
impact sur les finances des
collectivités locales et bien il faut
faire attention il n'aurait pas fallu le
voter à ce moment là alors le la baisse
des impôts de production par rapport à
l'augmentation de la compétitivité des
entreprises c'est une bonne chose
maintenant le danger par rapport à cette
fiscalité qui est en fait qui prive les
collectivités locales d'un levier
supplémentaire c'est l'autonomie
financière des collectivités
et depuis quand même plus de dix ans on
assiste à un mouvement de fond ça soit
sur la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle comme la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation et maintenant la
baisse des impôts de production c'est
qu'on essaye de remplacer une fiscalité
locale donc des ressources dites propres
pour les collectivités territoriales par
des dotations et donc on rend de plus en
plus dépendants les communes les
départements les régions de l'état et au
fur et à mesure on va les expliquer
quand je vois le projet de loi de
finances 2009 1 21 ou départ départ
entier de dotation de compensation sont
supprimées parce que mis dans les
variables
justement du projet de loi de finances
ça en dit long quand même sur la
trajectoire potentiel que pourra avoir
la dotation de compensation de la taxe
d'habitation dans les années à venir par
exemple donc prudents c'est clairement
sur la taxe d'habitation vous dit pour
le moment on est compensée à les
communes sont compensées à l'euro près
mais s'affichant sur gmail en termes
c'est ça pour vous attendez chaque année
il va falloir vérifier si à l'euro près
on va être compensée si ça suit la même
trajectoire que la dotation globale de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire avec cet
écrêtement de plus de 20000 commune en
2020 pour essayer de compenser alimenter
des communes pauvres qu'ils ne
deviennent pas plus riches pour autant
vous imaginez bien que dans dix ans je
mets le pari si on continue dans ce
système là que la dotation de
compensation sur la th sera proche de
zéro pour certaines communes et donc ça
veut dire qu'à des communes qui vont se
retrouver dans une situation financière
compliquée du fait de cette situation
cette taxe d'habitation quand c'est déjà
le cas pas par rapport à la suppression
d'apple habitations mais par rapport à
aube est drastique des dotations de
l'état
donc ce qu'il faut faire en termes de
propositions c'est véritablement
refondre la fiscalité locale
on a un système qui date de deux cents
ans
je suis désolé mais les quatre vieilles
on les a transposé ça fait 200 ans qu'on
est sur le même système de fiscalité
locale il faut repenser notre système
avoir un impôt unique moderne qui permet
d'avoir une base la plus large possible
c'est à dire des administrés du premier
rojo aux plus riches qui puisse
compenser et payer l'impôt par rapport
aux communes parce qu'il ya une rupture
du lien fiscal entre la commune et
l'administré tout n'est pas gratuit et
rien ne peut reposer sur la tarification
des services publics
allez on va aller du côté de lyon
maintenant stéphane heures et du lips
que tous les jours on va dans une
rédaction locale et on va retrouver
sébastien calmars bonjour sébastien
merci beaucoup d'être avec nos
journaliste au progrès
vous allez nous parler et bien de la
future skyline skyline c'est pas facile
à dire à la lyonnaise c'était la une du
progrès coup d'arrêt aux futurs projets
de tours oui alors la skyline c'est cet
alignement de grandes tours qu'on peut
voir par exemple à new york pour lyon on
va parler d'un futur plus ou moins
proche pour la mise en place d'un tel
projet peut-être moins proches que ce
corps est désiré gérard collomb du temps
où il régnait sur la ville et sur la
métropole de lyon les bouches de cette
skyline existait d'ailleurs déjà à lyon
avec la tour oxygène la tour incity ces
immeubles sont venus ces dernières
années accompagné la célèbre le célèbre
crayon du quartier des affaires de la
part dieu qui marque depuis les années
70 l'identité visuelle de la ville mais
la donne a changé depuis l'élection des
écologistes à la mairie et surtout à la
métropole de lyon au début de l'été
dernier c'est un projet qui a du plomb
dans l aile il bat pas dans son ensemble
mais la création des immeubles aime lyon
et m2 qui devrait abriter
essentiellement des bureaux des
commerces ou encore un hôtel cinq
étoiles n'emballe pas vraiment le nouvel
exécutif metropolit à leurs promoteurs
didier caudard breille patron lyonnais
du groupe dcb international qui a quand
même déjà investi près de 85 millions
d'euros dans ce projet annoncé comme
grandiose et ultramoderne pour avoir ces
opérations n'ont pas annulé mais un peu
contrarié le promoteur devra en tout cas
sans doute revoir en partie sa copie
pour rendre ces plantes tour plus
écolo-compatible et pourtant il y aura
bien des nouvelles tours à lyon dans
l'avenir sébastien oui puisqu'il d'ores
et déjà acquis c'est que les tours si
les kz2 et tout lyon seront livrés
théoriquement en 2021 et 2023 toujours
dans le quartier de la part dieu
et puis les projets de tours m liron et
m2 ne sont pas abandonner complètement
pour autant au contraire mail pour le m
lyon comme il le dit dans le progrès ce
mardi matin didier caudard breille donc
le promoteur espère avoir des gammes ans
et dès la fin de cette année 2020 et
obtenir son permis de construire
il projette la livraison de l'immeuble
pour 2024 pour le m2 en revanche le
promoteur dit qu'il devra sans doute
attendre l'année prochaine donc en 2021
pour simplement entré en discussion avec
la métropole 2
merci beaucoup sébastien pour ses
explications et tout ça c'est bien sûr à
la une du progrès aujourd'hui un lion
n'ira pas plus au coup d'arrêt aux
futurs projets de tours merci c'est 25
allemands d'avoir été avec nous depuis
lyon va regarder maintenant votre revue
de presse stéphane rugby avec alexandre
touzard qui revient
[Musique]